حل عام جديد ومع يومه الاول هجمات روسيه
بعشره المسيرات الايرانيه الصنع وفقا كياف
استهدفت مقاطعه عده هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه قالت ان القوه الروسيه خلال 24
ساعه استهدفت البلاد ب 31 صاروخا و12 ضربه
جويه واكثر من 70 قذيفه كافه اهتزت هي
ومدن اخرى في انحاء البلاد على وقع في
جرارات وتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن اسقاط
دفاعاته 45 مسيرتا قال انها ايرانيه الصنع
بينها 30
في اول ايام السنه برز فيه قصف صاروخي على
مدن الكرام تورسك وكوستاني
وفي ما يبدو ردا على التصريحات الاوكرانيه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الصواريخها
الدقيقه بعيده المدى استهدفت امس ما صنع
عسكريه اوكرانيه تستخدم لانتاج المسارات
الهجوميه بتت مواقع عسكريه روسيه صورا
قالت انها لقصف صاروخيه استهدف قاعده
للقوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
اخبرنيسيسكي وتحدث عن ان الامر يتعلق
بالفوج الثامن الذي يعد الافضل بين القوه
الخاصه الاوكرانيه عسكريه ايضا قال رئيس
مديريه الاستخبارات في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انه لا يزال لدى روسيا
احتياطيه صاروخيه كافيه لشن هجومين او
ثلاثه واسعه النطاق مستقبلا على عموم
اوكرانيا واضاف ان روسيا يمكنها انتاج مما
يصل الى 50 صاروخان من نوع كاليبر شهريا
وان اي هجوم روسي كبير سيحتاج الى نحو شهر
ونصف لانتاج الصواريخ الجديده تطورات تاتي
بينما اكدت الاستخاره الاوكرانيه شهر مارس
اداري المقبل سيكون صعبا على روسيا من
ناحيه نقص العدد والذخيره مضيفه ان النصر
الاوكراني يتمتله في استعاده حدود
اوكرانيا التي رسمت عام 91 بما فيها شبه
جزيره القرم
[موسيقى]